der Traum vom Eigenheim wird Ihnen
präsentiert von renovero für jedes
Projekt Handwerker einfach online finden
auf
[Applaus]
renovero.ch unsere
hausug
Zimmer die Berge bitte ein Traum soll
schaldklichkeit ut sich die Familie
knnecht ein Haus alles fängt
verheißungsvoll
an doch die Ereignisse überstürzen sich
es kommt zu
lieferengpessen für die Familie eine
zerreiprobe es gibt keinen Rückzugsort
für
mich
als es auf der Baustelle endlich losgeht
wird Mutter Erika Knecht
krank das ist schon Ruck
[Musik]
Familie so und dann hab wir vier
Schlafzimmer und das
Badzimmer hier ist die Welt noch in
ingen Ende
2021 in einem Jahr schon sollte auf
diesem Grundstück das Haus der Familie
Knecht stehen wollt ihr noch eine gute
Nachricht ihr könnt dann trampeln wie
euer Herz begehrt weil niemand mehr
unter uns
ist es wird toll nicht mehr in einer
Wohnung zu sein denn unsere Kinder sind
wirklich
laut nicht laut
lebendig ich hoffe es wird alles
entspannter
irgw
e ma vi
einfach dass sich der Hausbau um Monate
verzögern wird und Sie als Familie an
ihrer Grenzen kommen das ist zu diesem
Zeitpunkt alles noch weit
weg Mittagessen von Chefkoch Rolf Knecht
für seine Familie eher selten dass am
Mittag alle zusammen am Tisch
sitzenaterolf
und die gebürtige Kanadierin Erik KNE zu
90% als
headmion die beiden haben drei Kinder
die zu diesem Zeitpunkt jährige Stella
der ajährige
Hugo und die fjährige
la die Zweizimmerwohnung in Meiringen
ist eng die Vorfreude aufs Haus ist
riesig es gibt diesen bestimmten Look
von Schweizer
Küchen was ist falsch in Schweizer
Küchen sie sehen alle gleich aus schau
das ist die typische Schweizer
Küche ich finde es gibt keinen
individuellen
[Musik]
Stil die zu kleine Wohnung wird in den
nächsten Monaten immer wieder Thema sein
die Familie wohnt erst seit einem Jahr
hier zuvor war sie während Jahren in
Asien
mein Name ist Rolf ich bin kulinarischer
Direktor von Grand h
kualalumpur seit 2006 bin ich dabei und
war schon überall in
Asien es ist fast wie ein wahr
gewordener Traum denn mein Vater war
eine der ersten kulinarischen Chefs von
haat in
Asien kurz vor Corona nahm die Familie
Abschied von Asien und kam nach fast 20
Jahren Ausland zurück in die
Schweiz tu ich einfach auf Job wei will
du du FST immer wieder Null umzi das
istim schaffen so das ist sozial Leben
so jedes Mal wenn wir umz sind h ke
Kinder ich habe gemerkt dass Stella ein
Zuhause braucht für sie wurde es mit
jedem Umzug schwieriger neue Schule neue
Freunde
ein Haus kaufen war wie ein Bekenntnis
für mich da bleiben wir
jetzt am Anfang steht die Skizze dieses
Hauses wir g wo h spielen oder und
sozusagen über Nacht entscheiden Sie
sich für dieses Projekt blau völlig oder
also im Prinzip g mir knapp millionus
passieren auf dtigge Baubeschrieb glaub
und und zwei Skizze W jetzt da von
rerfassade Badzimmer ich glaube das
spontan B zu also ist kalkuliert Risiko
würde ich sagen ja keine Ahnung
was
[Musik]
ja ein Termin bei der Bank steht an für
den Hausbau müssen sich die beiden
Berufstätigen immer mehr Zeit
freischaufeln ja ich glaube jetzt RT ja
langsam
mit dem architek ich das
[Musik]
istigung die finanzielle Tragbarkeit
fürs Haus wird jetzt definitiv
berechnet J mal in etwa
das
genau Orang und
grün
in der Schweiz ist es wirklich schwierig
ein Haus zu kaufen wenn du in Kanada an
einem Ort vergleichbar mit Meiringen
bauen würdest wäre das absolut
erschwinglich Rolf und Erika Knecht
haben Glück sie werden sich das Haus
trotz zu wenig Eigenkapital und zu wenig
Einkommen leisten können dank
Erbschaft W der Erbschaft oder schenkig
w wir überk jetzt vonen Elter W kann
schell
maximum
genau grün
3% also Problem V der Tragbarkeit V der
Bank das heißt es g Hypothek Größe
680000 ja ist für mich unhe
Stress ich g nicht ger mit Geld um und
der alles ST will ja schon
stressvoll finde ich schon und wenn ich
der nicht
hat no viel schlimmer was rolfknecht
damit meint sie habe das Familienbudget
im Griff eher
nicht
[Musik]
danke wintereisbahnbetrieb auf dem
Dorfplatz in
[Musik]
Meiringen
rolfknecht macht Freiwilligenarbeit und
kocht ein indonesisches
nasigorengarta aber ich B verantwortlich
für Hotel bin ich f überall in indonesi
umereist und viel mit B geschaff und
schocky Farmer und
Kaffee wir
sind Rolf knnecht will sich an seinem
neuen Wohnort Meiringen integrieren ja D
machen wir zweim se ST du dann ist gut
und ich große Portion ist gut ja ja ich
find es
super Community man
findetchluss l spannend
super die ganze Familie ist da ich bin
hungrig können wir etwas zu Essen holen
ja hol dir was Mami komm was möchtest du
die Familie Knecht ist voller
[Musik]
Hoffnungen die älteste Tochter Stella
hat sich in der neuen Umgebung gut
eingelebt und in der Schule Freundinnen
gefunden die Familie rechnet damit dass
sie Weihnachten in einem Jahr bereits im
neuen Haus feiern kann
5 Monate später ist die Welt eine andere
in der Ukraine ist ein Krieg
ausgebrochen die Holzpreise sind massiv
gestiegen und es gibt
Lieferschwierigkeiten diverser
Baumaterialien das Bauprojekt
stockt um Klarheit zu schaffen gibt es
ein Treffen mit den Architekten
Alexandra Reimann und Patrick
Siedler
grundag müssen mal stoener
[Gelächter]
undkt ja das ja im Moment macht
nichtktion was machen sch
Herbst Herbst D Winter warte und Februar
März völlig nasse frühlich git denn dass
man den Hal im Sommer
oder sind ziemlich
ja innerhalb weniger Wochen wir
immeritfenster
finden okay einfach damit ihr wisst
jeden Monat den wir länger in unserer
Wohnung bleiben müssen kostet mich 5
Jahre meines
Lebens ich komme und
helfe
[Musik]
die Verschiebung des Baus um ein Jahr
ist ein riesendämpfer für die Familie
denn die Wohnsituation hat sich
zugespitzt deine Sonnenbrille ist mir zu
groß die fünjährige lara hat die seltene
Augenkrankheit
achsenfeldeger schon Operationen hat das
mädchiteeburt hinter sich Erne STT
für die Familie eine von vielen
Belastungen die älteste Tochter Stella
hat die Diagnose Asberger und bräuchte
Rückzugsmöglichkeiten genau wie Bruder
Hugo der auf dem ADHS Spektrum ist doch
Rückzug gibt's in dieser Wohnung nicht
also
daang wo direkt Schlafzimmer got
für Frau schen aber es ist
rückzugsgebi Tochter wo wenn wir Stu
Zimmer hi
und da hinen im Ecke ich schwalwies den
der Hugo oder
oder secret Spot secret
corner unterfah und dann hab wir da
Kinderzimmer wo jetzt gerade der Hugo
denen ist und küen ist al im Zimmer ist
eigentlich der wo meiste ruhbucht im
Moment
es gibt keinen Rückzugsort in diesem
Haus es fühlt sich an als wäre mein
Nervensystem dauernd
aktiviert denn es ist immer
Chaos
weg Spielzeug rumschmeißt hör auf Hugo
es ist nicht okay für mich
okay okay es gibt magessen W wir jetzt
wirklich so viel Konflikt h mit mit dem
Wohnen
oder mit dem fehlenden Platz sind wir
jetzt jetzt geht's halt
dieoni geraloni W wir absolut weiger zum
caneloni Essen geht für die halelmarone
dann haben wir die verschiedene Salat
sal essen wenn machen noch Stund
Konflikt und der Konflikt wird noch
Schlimmerem
Rückzugsort und alle häsig sind und dann
ja
W mindest ist einfacher wenn halb Stunde
länger
K die Wohnung nur als Übergang gedacht
wird zum
Langzeitprovisorium ichück Schwiz
idealisiert we ich
wirklichwiz alles wird
gut es ist besser für Familie
meeim wohnen ist
einfacher weniger Stress oder und das
wirklich
idealisiert und
den und
vorgestellt zu diesem Zeitpunkt
überlegen sich Erika und
rolfkteren das Hausprojekt abchen eine
andereohnung eine Mietwohnung für eine
fünfköpfige Familie zu finden schier
unmöglich auch in
Meiringen schau es wird ein scheißjahr
aber es ist ein Jahr es sind nicht 20
Jahre und ich werde 20 Jahre in diesem
Haus
leben ein chinesisches Sprichwort sagt
du musst viel Bitterkeit Essen das
machen wir
jetzt danach hast du die süße Erfahrung
eines daheims für die
und eigene Schlafzimmer mit einer Tür
Wohneigentum ist für viele hier zu Lande
ein Traum doch nur 30% aller Schweizer
Haushalte haben das nötige Kapital um
sich ein durchschnittliches
Einfamilienhaus leisten zu
[Musik]
können spartenstich
endlich ein Rückzug vom Projekt wäre
jetzt mit hohen Kosten
[Musik]
verbunden war es es war cool gute Arbeit
die baunternehmung hat für Rolf und
Erika Knecht ein Spatenstich Ritual
vorbereitet
Problem gen diefall
ja
Treff mer viel mal wünsche alles
Gute fühlt sich jetzt irgendwie real
an es ist so schräg wenn du dir
vorstellst dass wir jetzt mit dem Bau
eigentlich fertig sein
sollten konzentriere dich aufs
positive ja ein Jahr ein
Jahr in den nächsten D Monaten werden
Baumeisterarbeiten
ausgeführt das Fundament wird gegossen
die Kanalisation gemacht und die
Werkleitung
angeschlossen dann ruht das Projekt über
den
[Musik]
Winter also ist absolut Privileg und ich
meine ich B wo schon S junge Jahr
politisch selinks
ist Diskussionen W ich gewt mit de
ganzen Willen wie viel Platz dir die
verschwend oder t geschafft
hab in der fabrikim Bahnhof wo wir sind
und setetzt und jetzt
hab das ist nur Gegensatz oder und was
so mini ausred ist oder Mini wie sag
justification ist wir bauen
nachhaltig wir bauen wirklich für es ist
nicht kationssobjekt es ist nicht
zweitw mal als feriew informiert es ist
für Termin bei der Notarin in
Meiringen rolfknechts Eltern knüpfen
ihre Schenkung an eine
Bedingung diese soll schriftlich
festgehalten
werden also der war das Dokument wo ihr
drin regelt dass ihr oder die
drüeminsame Kind im Fall vor trenig oder
vor scheidig wier hin gemeinsame
legenschaft B wohneen zammen mit demz
berechtig der tere Teil es ist aber so
dass es Gericht im strittfall eine setge
veriebare knitbunde ist als im
strittfall W das Gericht einfach im Sinn
vom Kindeswohl entscheiden ist das so
ironik für euch beide
okay für dich oder hast Du
fragen obwohl rechtlich nicht bindend
sei diese gemeinsame Erklärung wichtig
sagen die Eltern von Rolf
Knecht vonter mir selber h glaub
nichtemt so
aber ja so unterschrieben und das man
sicher machen dass plat
passiert ich bin sehr dankbar für die
Unterstützung von Rolfs
Eltern
aber wie Rolf schon sagte wir hätten es
wahrscheinlich ein bisschen anders
gelöst doch weil seine Eltern so
großzügig sind ist es wichtig für mich
ihr anlegen ernst zu
[Musik]
nehmen Besuch bei der Architektin rol
und KNE wollen das privaus von no ein
denuspieren zu
lassen was ist das das ist
chromstall gen aber das ist
speziäig
sicher Gre Thema Wunsch und Realität
klaen weit auseinander was gefällt ist
teuer z.B weiße
glattputzwände z.B machen zum Holz nicht
alle machen
sp rol unsere Kinder werden das kaputt
machen ich weiß aber schau du träumst
von Oberflächen ich von
Schubladen aber das ist
Standard genau genau wenn wir jetzt das
sitzfenster machen wenn Schubladen das
Kind SP DAF super h
od
spe
ja ich Hof haben
[Musik]
das für die freistehende Badewanne wir
das Geld
ausreichen viele andere Träume werden am
budg schitern
wegen der Änderungswünsche bahnen sich
bereits jetzt hohe Mehrkosten
[Musik]
an in der Zimmerei ist
Hochbetrieb ein Jahr zuvor war hier
Stillstand der Markt hatte verrückt
gespielt das ist
vorbei
los das ist
extrem mehr
als
ja
und
Doppel das
noch
ausnahmituation die Zimmerei fertigt im
Betrieb Wende und Böden vor Vorort in
Meiringen werden dann die Elemente
montiertilding Home und das stimmt ja
gar nicht
technische Vorgang
home Z Monate später ist es soweit die
Holzwände werden
aufgerichtet für Erika und rolfknecht
eine riesige
Erleichterung
es ist wirklich großartig das zu
sehen ich bin
glücklich jetzt müssen die definitiven
Entscheidungen für die Innenausstattung
gefällt
werden da wird es noch ein bisschen
Platz haben dazwischen
oder dort haben wir einen Kühlschrank
und ein
Regal ich glaube die
küel ist sie
90 der Innenausbau ist Erik kncht sehr
wichtig vom standardobjekt dass sie
ursprünglich gekauft haben weichen die
beiden immer wieder ab aktuelle
Mehrkosten deshalb 40 000
Franken ich habe mit meinem Vater
darüber gesprochen und er sagte wenn du
kannst mach wirklich was du
willst ein guter Rad wir bauen nur
einmal wir vergessen manchmal dass Leute
einmal
bauen wir die immer wieder Häuser bauen
sind uns das manchmal zu wenig
bewusst gut wenn ihr uns sagt wie
speziell es für euch ist das macht es
auch speziell für
uns es ist das erste Mal dass wir ein
Haus haben das erste Mal dass wir für
immer an einem Ort bleiben werden und
unsere Kinder Wurzeln schlagen
können Erika Knecht ist zu diesem
Zeitpunkt krank geschrieben und
vorübergehend in einer
Klinik diesen Moment habe sie nicht
verpassen wollen darum sei sie hier ihre
Diagnose Burnout mit dem Bau habe die
Krankheit nichts zu tun sagt Erika
Knecht im Gegenteil was hier geschehe
freue sie krank habe sie die Situation
am Arbeitsplatz
gemacht
burnout ist als würdest du dich selbst
verlieren alles ist dir zu viel du
fühlst dich komplett
überfordert ich erinnere mich dass ich
vor dem Computer saß und nicht mehr
entscheiden konnte in welchen Ordner ich
die Emails
ablege
oder ich stand in der Küche und fragte
mich wie muss ich die aufwaschmaschine
ausräumen was ich gelernt habe burnout
ist nicht was du denkst es ist nicht
dass du zu wenige Sonntage draußen
verbringst und ein Buch liest burnout
ist nicht dass du zu viele Stunden
arbeitest Burnout hat nur mit dem
Zusammenspiel zwischen Individuum und
der Struktur zu tun
mitten in dieser schwierigen Zeit
wechselt rolfknecht den
Job er wird Küchenchef in einem
Parkhotel am tunersee und führt ein Team
von 30 Mitarbeiterinnen und Mitarbeiter
er will im Betrieb Akzente setzen z.
mehr Angebote aus der Region für die
Region chsel Krankheit und ein Hausbau
wie hoch ist derzeit die Belastung du im
Moment oder mit der Erik wo Moment krank
ist und husbau neuah
fang jetzt nicht nehme d Ich vi wen
immer wenn ich w schon weg entlung und
freit gibt
[Musik]
esatener
einschneidend und der Kostendruck auf
der Baustelle
steigt auch überleid im letzte Z
J to much oder es wir viel das got in
richtig das das B schon überlegen ob das
Le und dann ist irgendwie
ja mitgegangen mit gefangen kan eigent
gar nicht mus mit mir kan eigentlich nur
S fertig Stopp wenn wenn mir das
halbfertige Hus
verkaufen so dass mir alles K abzahlen
wir jetzt sch Hypothek oder und sch die
Moment
wenn B Telefon D kom das neues E-Mail
und nur so die Notifikation oder so
Zusatzkosten mehr kosten und dann
Scheiße mal mal Stunden nicht
aufen was jetzt schon wieder mehr
kostet und den das Stress die
sch Rolf Knecht hat bei den Abrechnungen
festgestellt dass Ihre Änderungswünsche
hohe Mehrkosten generieren um zu sparen
würde er gern direkt mit den Händlern
verhandeln doch das geht nicht er will
von den Architekten wissen warum
hallo W die spezielle h agesucht h und
und die größer badwen und was auch immer
oder undter sich jetzt
ziemlichzellt oder will will wir Recht
viänderwünsch oder und jetzt meine Frage
wieso muss das zerst zum Architekt g
wieso hat jetzt Bau die Zeichn nicht
direkt schicken W ich den sen die
Induktion
istuswechsel macht was wieso Gott es
eigentlich über ein Architekt wenn man
so macht und nicht über mich als direkt
du du
bist
genauintft oder
das ist das ist oder das ist nicht so
das ist ja wirklich ihrufer oder war
viel einfacher wenn wir die SA verkaufen
wenn der Käufer einfach das wir machen
wo mir Vorschlag oder Vorschlag W
einfach umsetzen da gab auch für euch ke
mehr kostte ja und dann se aus wen mir
eigentlich Plan der B ist zwischen hell
und dunkel W Platte ist so
30 zwischen hell und dunkel
ja und dann umsetz W aber jetzt vier
Kufer und das hab wir ja zum Teil
komplett anders machen dann müssen wir
ja immer wieder machen Mass muss zum
untern
musordin
St zeag mit amfer gar nicht W als selber
bestimmen Architektin Reimann sagt von
allen vier Käufern hätten Knechts am
meisten Änderungswünsche gehabt künftig
würden sie ihrer Kundschaft nicht
zuletzt aufgrund dieser Erfahrungen
weniger Wahlmöglichkeiten
anbieten ein paar Wochen später die
Zimmerei montiert die
Holzfassade bei einem spontanen
Baustellenbesuch ist rolfknecht
überrascht wie viel Handarbeit dahinter
steckt
baustell die Außendämmung und
Holzabdeckung des
Hauses
hausbesitzerkcht wird in die
Präzisionsarbeit
eingeführt
nicht cool ja ich mega schön wirklich
vorwärs jetzt jedes Mal wenn
K und Geld her das ja
wenn die L Einzel Z ist
megaand hat die so nicht denkt muss ich
ehrlich
[Musik]
sagen
seit d Jahren beschäftigen sich Rolf und
Erika Knecht nun mit ihrem
Hausbau das Bauprojekt habe ihr Leben
und ihre Beziehung verändert sagen die
[Musik]
beiden
ter schat dann W dünkler
heller vor Luxus mir das Le wo mir
eigentlich n müssen entscheideno
Arbeitgeber eig Plan das ist ein Vorteil
Nachteil schlussendlich vien ist
aber Luxus Lifestyle überall wo wir
her
jetzt
gemeinsam selber definieren ich schon
Gefühl sind gewachsen wir h jetzt
vielleicht
andereo andere Art und wi W
[Musik]
Konflikt willst du auchprieren nein
danke ich glaube rolf hat einige
zentrale Dinge verstanden unsere
Beziehung hat sich vertieft er weiß
jetzt wie wichtig mir gleichberechtigte
Finanzen sind und ich glaube auch er
weiß jetzt wie wichtig mir meine
Wohnumgebung ist auch wenn es manchmal
Details sind es hilft meiner mentalen
Gesundheit Erika Knecht geht es
gesundheitlich besser sie ist zurück aus
der
Klinik Kinder haben sich in Meiringen
eingelebt haben Freundschaften
geschlossen alle sind
angekommen noch knapp einen Monat bis
zur
Schlüsselübergabe die Überbauung wird
pünktlich fertig werden rolfknechts
Eltern die Sponsoren sehen zum ersten
Mal das fast fertige
hausf
absolut
genau nein
Schuh zum Teil und da ist wirklich meh
Garderobe für Jacke und Rucksack und
alles das Z
oder wie viel Arbeit im Haus steckt
veranschaulicht hausbesitzerkcht seinen
Eltern am Beispiel der
Hausfassade das ist mich wie typisch
schwizerisch oder das Eck
auch alles noch noch gestrichen mit der
F bevor sie in geschlagen das einfach
dae Holz das ist
das jaoh aber
wenn5 Frank pro
Stund geht primärum dass wirhen Wasem
gelden oder Sie müssen nicht warten bis
wir tot sind und ich freut dass ich
geseh die Kinder dürf jetzt so groß
und die Freiheit was sie
as das ist für die Kinder
ungeug
[Musik]
ganz
ganz das
ist
[Musik]
schön
D Wochen später Tag der
Hausübergabe die Familie ist am packen
für den
Umzug
neu ja aber
Inter ich romantisch
vorellt
st
und und
[Musik]
ja am ersten Abend will ein Teil der
Familie im neuen Haus kampieren
rolfknecht sucht einen
Schlafsack nein nicht
mit nicht cool wenn der
Vater B du der Mama da
ja ich habe vor zwei Wochen mit Packen
begonnen und fühlte mich so
organisiert jetzt nicht
mehr es ist als wärst du volle Fahrt
unterwegst und auf einmal verlierst du
ein Rad und noch was und alles fällt
auseinander so fühlt es sich hier
drinnen an
mitten im Durcheinander müssen die
Eltern los für die
Schlüsselübergabe
herkommen Schüss
FF
genau die Hausübergabe ist ein
offizieller Akt die Besitzer müssen
begutachten ob alles wie abgemacht da
ist und
funktioniert
im Eingangsbereich entdeckt Erika Knecht
eine
Unsauberkeit hier braucht es noch etwas
Farbe Architekt und Architektin notieren
was es noch zu erledigen
gilt Architektin Reimann macht auf einen
Planungsfehler aufmerksam der noch
behoben
wird mit zwei Dingen die fehlen haben
die neuen hausbesitzenden nicht
gerechnet beim Ofen ist nur ein Loch in
der Decke
und im oberen Stock sind zwei
Kinderzimmer
offen ich dachte hier haben wir eine
Schiebetüre sind Sache vorsichtig
nur immer mit oder und jetzt mit
wahscheinlich wieder irgendwo
ja ja aber das ist
ich
vorsichtig
das
[Musik]
das das
istz mir dem ganz ch
vöig
m viel wichtiger we die richtige PL am
richtigen Ort oder alles dem zitum
definiert
Word das das funktioniert m
hauptsach Ofen und Türe müssen Sie
selbst einbauen andere kleine Mängel
übernimmt das
Architekturbüro damit ist der Bau
offiziell
übergeben
die Geduld die ihr uns gegeben habt
lässt uns so viel Freude haben am Haus
ihr habt auf kleinste Details Rücksicht
genommen und das finde ich wichtig denn
wenn ich jetzt etwas nicht mag werde ich
es die nächsten 20 Jahre nicht mögen und
es würde von Tag zu Tag
schlimmer weil ihr Geduld mit uns hattet
ist das nicht
passiert
[Musik]
soer
Abfahrt mit dem Gepäck für die erste
Nacht die Familie hat kein Auto und
pendelt zu Fuß oder mit dem Fahrrad
zwischen alter Wohnung und neuem
[Musik]
Haus die Kinder sehen das fertige Haus
zum ersten
Mal hier den Schrank siehst wie viel
Platz da
ist papa du hast gesagt wir ein Garten
wie haben einen Garten das ist kein
Garten der Garten ist rundum das ist
kein Garten da ist noch kein Gras das
kommt noch kleine Enttäuschungen und
kleine Freuden nach D Jahren sind sie
nun also in ihrem
Haus ich hoffe unser Leben wird sich
komplett verändern die Kinder werden nie
mehr streiten sie werden Schuhe und
Kleider immer schön hinstellen das Haus
wird nie mehr schmutzig
sein ich
einfachig hektisch
einfach
auch weniger hektisch
dann doch aufregend wird es in dieser
Familie wohl immer bleiben beim
Aufstellen der provisorischen liege im
Elternschlafzimmer taucht die Frage auf
ist da überhaupt ausreichend Platz für
ihr Bett
[Musik]
das passt
[Applaus]
[Musik]
schon du willst in deinem eigenen Zimmer
schlafen ja in meinem Zimmer ganz allein
ja000en en Rolf und Erika Knecht
schlussendlich für Ihr Haus 80 000
Franken mehr Kosten wegen ihrer
Sonderwünsche viel Geld doch wie sagte
Erika Knecht man baut nur einmal und
verbringt dann sein restliches Leben in
diesem
[Musik]
Haus der Traum v igenheim wurde Ihnen
präsentiert von renovero für jedes
Projekt Handwerker einfach online finden
auf
renovero.ch